many of us probably have a nagging
feeling that we don't listen enough to
other people here we're not going to
make the guilt worse by telling you that
listening is a good thing worthy but in
fact rather dull we're going to show you
that listening to others is first and
foremost an interesting thing to do
something that could be as pleasurable
for you as it is for your speaking
companion we commonly locate pleasure in
conversation as follows talking about
myself fun and hearing you talking about
you sizzling and as a result we try to
minimize how much we're listening and
maximize how much we're talking because
that's how it feels that will have the
most interesting lives but is this
analysis of a pleasure really accurate
of course there is a basic pleasure to
be had in as we put it here in the sound
of our own voice but we can also venture
that this isn't a real pleasure but
talking about ourselves the real
pleasure talking about our Sarris lies
in understanding of them becoming
clearer about who we are what we feel
what we're wanted to what we might do
pleasure talking about ourselves life in
essence in first clarification not
merely or primarily in hearing our own
voices generally we tend to believe that
self clarification we default if we
ourselves are actually a total corporate
farming instinct and redemptive
attraction we can sometimes end up then
son of hammock bits of ourselves
I'm definite to the stories that are
hard to walk well this might sound like
a New York man you sentimental fantasy
but it is soberly true and the proof
lies in an area we know very well
literature
novels are stories of other people that
we don't mind hearing because they are
also at their best stories that teach us
about ourselves we're prepared to spend
hours hearing other people like Tolstoy
or Proust or Virginia Woolf talking
about their ideas and adventures and
remarkably we don't mind not getting a
single word of our own into the arena
because we're actively understanding
bits of ourselves by
they're stories this is what Marcel
Proust had to say on this he wrote every
reader of a novel is in effect the
reader of his own life whose shape he is
better able to appreciate thanks to the
spectacles which the novelist has
offered him we might reply that this is
all very well but that the average
person we have to listen to is a lot
less interesting than Marcel Proust so
no wonder we want to listen to the
novelist and not the average person but
the people we have around us are a lot
more interesting than we tend to think
if only we knew how to listen to them
and edit them properly the reason why
so-called great writers are interesting
to listen to even when they give that
themselves is that they've mastered the
tricks for teasing out from their
experiences what is universally relevant
from what is locally specific so-called
great writers might be telling us a
story about their arms childhood or a
trip to the woods but in the way they
tell us these things they will be
adapted at Universal dimension so that
their stories end up being not just
local anecdotes with no echoes in the
minds of others but Universal stories
that simultaneously in the rate pages in
the Universal book of humankind they
entertain their stories and our own in
truth we are all living out stories in
the universal book of humankind but
we're apt to describe this life so badly
to get so bogged down in local details
of unnecessary digressions that we bore
our audiences giving listening to
someone very negative associations we
haven't got the wrong sort of life we
have the wrong techniques for rating
that life and by narrating badly we
helped to create an enduring suspicion
of the act but having to listen to
someone else speak here is some of what
goes wrong when we try to narrate our
lands firstly we keep latching on to
factual details we go on about times
places external movements not realizing
that these become interesting
only when people say what they feel
about
what happened not really what happened
second thing we often get overwhelmed by
an emotion we experienced and insist
upon it rather than attempting to
explain it so we say again and again it
was so beautiful or it was a scariest
thing in the whole world but without
accurately unpacking the feeling and
thereby being able to make it live in
somebody else's mind thirdly because
when we promise to get a bit interesting
with our narration we often take fright
we have scared of our own emotions which
can threaten to trigger feelings of
unbearable sadness confusion or
excitement
we take flight into superficiality
fourthly another problem we don't stick
with one story there is so much in our
minds we keep opening up new subtle
we're not focusing when the good
listener encounters these sort of
unfortunate ways of talking they don't
panic they try to act like good editors
being a good listener is like being a
good editor in a publishing house
consider the relationship between a
famous American writer Raymond Carver
and his New York editor Gordon lish at
the publishing house of Alfred Knopf
lish heavily edited Carver thought as we
might put it he listened to him in a
hugely creative and transformative way a
way that can teach us about the art of
listening in ordinary life as well lish
hugely boosted Carver's confidence you
made him feel that the world was
listening and that it was worth properly
unpacking his experiences he did the
editorial equivalent of what in
conversation we can call looking closely
into someone's eyes with tenderness
focus and sympathy secondly lish stalked
Carver from descending into local PDM he
took Carver's experiences in rural
America and gave him a Universal
dimension ensuring a Carver he's now
famous in Korea in Germany as well
lastik he's topped Carver digressing he
kept him focused on a central theme in
each story he wrote what we need to know
is listener is a version of what wish
did for car and listening we can also
shake keys out or cut out emphasized far
in the names getting the latent real
good story to emerge from our companions
mind so when listening
stop your companion digressing say
things like so a minute ago you were
saying
welcome back to the larval Cathedral and
emotionally alive part of the story
call them away from numb surface detail
get them to the cookie for emotional
reality sorrow what did that feel like
for you allow for the unusual and the
weird use signs that suggest a new
promise maybe someone is about to say
that they felt attached to their fists
or stole money from the company don't do
anything that might close off a
vulnerable confession say go on your to
judge your a friend the good listener
knows that one of the best ways to
understand an issue in one's own life is
to hear it discussed through the life of
someone else and furthermore they have
the editing skills to make sure they can
find themselves in the words of others
that way listening will no longer be a
chore it will be about the most
interesting thing we can ever do with
somebody else we believe in making the
world a more emotionally intelligent
place and to that end we've now also
published some extraordinary books as
well as other merchandise that
reinforces some of the themes
illustrated in our videos please click
on the link below to see more